everyone is like you say that because
you have money I'm like go talk to
everybody who knew me at 13 19 25. go
talk to them you know me now go talk to
everybody where I was thinking
making 45 000 a year happy as
ing stuff
I really genuinely understand that I
swear the fact that there are so many
immigrant parents that had the same
amount of money as your parents right
and didn't deploy it as a struggle that
perspective is the game that is a very
different thing and that is where I get
fascinated that's zero judgment on your
parents my I'm just talking macro the
thing I'm talking about is what we're
doing right now it's I will show you
unlimited tens of millions people on
Earth but dramatically less money than
your parents and didn't deem it a
struggle that is what I'm thinking about
every day of my life of how to like
capture that as a conversation because I
think it would unlock happiness in a
totally different way